Film Courage: Brad can you take us through how
you lit certain scenes for A California Christmas?
Brad Rushing, Cinematographer: We have this one
here where Lauren [Writer/Actress Lauren Swickard]
is on the phone. That's a scene Cali's bedroom.
I remember it's on the second floor and when
Shaun [Director Shaun Paul Piccinino] said he
wanted to shoot in that bedroom I was like Okay,
I’m going to have to get an extra high stand.
So we specifically ordered an Avenger stand for
this shot and then also there's a scene in mom's
bedroom where she's sick and she's bed bound. That
one also we needed that Avenger stand because a
normal stand would not get us up to an altitude
where we could get a good angle like we'd be
pointing up, so that's a special stand. We shot
it in the day with an M18 which is the 1800 Watt
HMI Par. I remember in that moment worrying that
there was a little too much glare and even when we
did the color grade I was like Shaun, you want to
make that go away a little bit he's like Oh,
no I love it. He was right, it's beautiful but
I'm just it's glare is just one of those things
you know just like a flare you know it it can be
aesthetically pleasing or it can be you know
an obnoxious artifact and and it's just a fine
line and it's it's really nice in in this scene
that was one thing I thought about and but this
is a very simply lit scene I mean it was I think
we may have put some a negative fill behind the
camera you know put some black up just to put a
little bit of contrast in it because that light
was bouncing off of those white walls but not
a lot not a lot going on there we just kept it
simple and and let that window do its thing we
also we we pick her up with a camera move that
a pan that we pick her up coming in the door and
then we follow her over to where she's standing
in front of that window so that's a a nice
transition too and I think that was the only
shot we did I don't know if we did two sizes
of that if we did it was only two sizes
not a lot of coverage that was one of those scenes
we shot simple and quick and and she just you know
she just nailed it so here we have the barn scene
yeah I remember when we were scouting this angle
and Shaun saw that I mean behind us is is kind of
just a blind little cubicle almost like a stall
but it wasn't enclosed so I'm not really sure
what its purpose was and then to the left was
a little area with some machinery that was kind of
I guess because it's a dairy farm I got them maybe
they milk the cows and pump it into that stuff but
I don't know if it ended up in the movie but that
shot is actually it was on some it was on a dana
dolly on speed rails so when we came to it we just
started pushing in pushing in pushing in and I'm
not sure if they used that push-in or if they cut
in after we stopped and it's always tricky when
you're in the shade with something bright outside
you're always kind of worried that you don't want
to under expose this and then you don't want to
overexpose that and clip it so it's a matter of
you know finding that balance and then also maybe
bringing up the inside a little bit and so the
rim light on that was coming from an m18 again
that hmi par and I don't believe there was any
diffusion it was probably just clean and hard and
that was just coming from from off camera to put
that rim on him and then I had a an airy sky panel
you know back up against the wall just putting a
little bit of fill to lift it up I shot it on a
red helium which has the capacity to shoot what
they call hdrx which theoretically extends the
dynamic range because it it shoots alternating
images it it it shoots actually 48 frames
and so one is one exposure and then the other is
an offset exposure and then it alternates and and
that offset like if you stop it down two stops it
kind of extends your dynamic range by two stops
and then there's a process in post where you can
bring that information back in I don't think I use
that here I remember thinking I used it a little
more than I actually did because when we got into
the color grade I don't know if we ever actually
invoked that even though it was in some shots but
again it's just one of those tricky things and if
I had shot that on film i'd have been very nervous
and i'd had a spot meter in there just metering
all those values but as it was you know I was just
looking at the monitor you know i've been shooting
for so long exposing to monitors and I just
trust that if it's a properly calibrated monitor
and then I have a histogram or a waveform that I
can see the values i've done it enough times
that I just trust that process so I set the
exposure where I wasn't losing any information
and what I may have done I don't remember this
specifically but in something like that is I might
under expose the foreground just a little bit
you know just to to pull those highlights down
just to ensure that they're not clipping because
I know in post as long as I don't crush that those
shadows I can still bring them up a little bit
this is also seems like another outside the
barn or around the barn shop yeah that's a that
is a barn but it's a different barn but it's
funny that you should say that because we had
barn as a location in the script and they're like
physically completely different places you know
one was like for the dairy cows and then this
was more of a storage shed and honestly you know
cooper did you know michael cooper our production
designer did a really good job of dressing it
because you know from the outside it looks like
a barn but you go inside it just looks like a
great big storage shed you know so he went
in there and and pitched that hay in there
it was kind of fortuitous because it was such
a big space and I was like my god where am I
going to hide a light you know I mean I'm going
to I want to put a backlight on him but how am I
going to hide a light and and what I ended up
deciding is kind of like the story I told you
about the shoot where I put the tape on the light
is I just shoved that light right back there in
the shot and had them wrap it with black duvetyne
so it's there the light's there it's just dark and
you can't or the stand you get it's dark and
you can't see it and then up above the frame
is the light that's lighting them when we shot the
master scene I think I can't remember if this was
supposed to be day or night I can't remember but
when we shot the master it was dusk and so I had
to match that so this by the time we shot this
it was night it was pitch black so there really
wouldn't have been any frontal light on them at
all and what I did is I put a 12 by ultra bounce
out in front of the door and then I took one
of the sky panels and I color matched it to the
daylight by eye you know because again i've just
done it so many times that I feel I have really
good instincts matching the color and dimmed it
way way way way down you know so it wasn't a lot
of so it wasn't super bright in retrospect after I
shot it I kind of wished I had made that backlight
a little warmer but you know maybe that's noodling
you know they say a work of art is never finished
it's just abandoned and so you know it's probably
perfect just like it is and that was just me
you know wanting to nudge it some more but it
was very fortunate because it looks nice in
this in this 50 52 shot and I was thinking when I
go in for coverage am I going to have to you know
move that light around so that it's flattering
and and like so many scenes on this movie we
just didn't have a lot of time we went in for
coverage and it looked pretty good and the only
thing I really did instead of moving the light
is I would just angle them I would cheat their
position a little bit to make it a little bit
more flattering so the geometry of their position
in that space changed from the master but it's
such a tiny cheat that the audience can't tell
and it would like I said it was just made the
light a little bit more flattering on their faces
we have the interior bar yeah you know
I was scared to death to do this bar
from the time I read it in the script and I was
like you know can I please have a pre-light day
or a half a pre-light day and it's like it's just
there was no way because it was a working bar and
it was too far away from our location to send
anybody off so it was like you're gonna have to do
it on the day of I have worked with rgb led lights
pretty regularly now for about three or four years
but I had never lit in a bar seen interior with
them yet and that was a lot of lights and I'm just
like you know in the old days you'd be sticking
stuff up there and sleeving it with gels and then
you'd have cables to run across the ceiling and
tack up and hide and then you drop them all down
you know in a place that's like where are we
never going to look or if we do look there now
we're going to have to move it so you know there
was all of that but we used the estero titans that
are battery powered so there was no cables at all
because they were rgb led we could just dial in
the color and boom there it was blue no no gelling
no nothing and and you know our gaffer calambarus
had everything connected to an app on the phone
so he could just you know change the brightness
turn some of them off you know because in
different angles we would turn them off just
because we didn't want that spill and right now
I'm talking about the blue lights the cobalt blue
lights which I love that color I love cobalt
blue and and that was kind of an easy easy color
the thing that worried me was I didn't know
how long the batteries were going to last I'm
thinking my god you know we're going to have to
turn them off between takes and then at lunch
you're going to have to put them on charge
and he said yeah no they'll last and and and
we never put him on charge when he zip tied him
in that's the other thing is they found a way to
zip tie him into the ceiling because and I don't
even know what they fixed those zip ties to but
but I was I was also worried about how are you
going to get them up there without you know grip
crap that we see in the shot because you see shots
where you see the ceiling you see those tubes
but you know they look they look natural they
look like they belonged so I was very happy about
that and and the batteries just lasted and lasted
the red light in the back again was was kind of a
happy accident because that was the backlight for
caitlyn who was on the stage playing the keyboard
and that was one of the rarer instances of using
tungsten fresnels and I think those were either
300s or or 150s that we we popped back there you
know hanging down from the ceiling I think what
they did is they I think they put a pole cat up
you know as a small area so they put a little
like a an extendable metal telescoping pole cat
and then they just hung those off of there and
and you do see them a couple of times and they
look like you know little lights but it's like
oh they're stage lights whatever we put the
red gel and and then it just motivated that
from that direction and so it was very natural in
this shot to use it there and then for the white
light on their faces again I used the Astera
Titan s now I just I set them down on the bar
and I dimmed them down and this looks like a
production still because in the movie that light's
not as bright on their faces and this is probably
somebody snapped it while we were setting up
but it's just so beautiful and I really like
uplight I really like the quality of uplight but
you have to be careful with it especially you know
with women you want to make look beautiful because
if you get the angle wrong it's going to look like
a horror movie you know you have to find that just
that that sweet spot and and again there's
no formula it depends on the person's face
it depends on the actions with the face and
with Lauren what we did is we ended up pulling
it just a little bit closer to josh you know to
make it look nice on her but I just love it and
and then in the wider shots we didn't have it on
the counter I hid it just on the other side of the
counter so she still kind of had had that feeling
of it but when we went in for the close-ups and
we wanted to look beautiful we pulled it out
on the counter and we found that sweet spot
and then when we reversed for him we did the same
thing we just pulled a little bit away and we did
the same thing when we shot Ali Afshar for Leo
because he as you know comes into this scene
and one of the things I was worried about
and if i'd had time i'd have fiddled with it
I was worried that the light on that jute box
was too bright because it's kind of clipping out
and I have no control over that I would have had
to gel it or I would have had to make my lights
brighter and Shaun said you know I'm fine with it
so we just let it go great this is looks like the
airbnb or the hotel that they're staying at
yeah so this this shot is in the movie it's
a place that Leo rents to put up manny you know
because they want manny to disappear for reasons
that are revealed in the film and that's the place
that they're renting out and I really I love this
you know because for one thing the fire light now
in this the fire light is just natural fire light
but when I went in for coverage again I used the
Astera Titan s and I would use I did the fire
flicker effect on them because the fire is really
not once you get in there and you're filming
it's not bright enough to to light the faces in
a flattering way obviously for the wide shots I
had to go with what we didn't have a cg budget to
paint lights out and I had nowhere to hide them so
I just had to go with available light for those
guys back there although you know now that I'm
looking about it there may be a tube hidden hidden
down on the other side of that fire pit I guess I
don't remember for sure but anyway I just I love
the the quality of those titans when they were
doing the fire light this is one of my favorite
scenes in the movie and the other thing is the
night lighting the moonlighting on josh and and
the yard and then in the reverse on Connor's truck
you know it's kind of hard to hit that sweet spot
because you know some people tend to over light
night and I just gotta hate the night moonlight
that's too bright and just looks absolutely fake
and then on the other end of that spectrum is is
the moonlight that's just so bloody dark and it's
like you know you can't see detail and you're
struggling and that might work well in a horror
movie but I think in a romantic comedy Christmas
movie that's just not the place to go so you know
I was very happy with the ratio here I mean it
feels you see josh clearly but it feels like he's
dark and and I love the the color shift between
the blue and the warm I think it's just a really
pretty frame and I was very satisfied with that
here we have the breakfast table the breakfast
table yes so pretty sure this is one of the ones
which was shot at night and we put a silk or not
as yeah maybe it was a silk I think it was a frame
of diffusion like 250 or 216 that we threw up in
that window behind there and then you see a sliver
through the door of the other room which not only
did we have to put diffusion in that window but I
had to punch more light just to glow the ambience
in the room so that it felt like daylight because
it was just the window lit the room was dark and
it just you could tell that something was wrong
so it took a little more time than you might
think to get this right and and by the way you
know we were talking about this scene earlier
and I said we started shooting it in the daytime
so so that ambient light wasn't a problem then in
the other room that was another thing that had to
be added the other thing about the the diffusion
it wasn't on the window it was backed away from
the window because I have two m18s crossing coming
through there with a little bit of backlight so
if I put it up against the window I would have
lost that quality another thing is I'm pretty sure
it was this scene it's definitely the scene when
josh leaves when josh when she grabs this hat you
forgot something I put a couple of astero titans
up on top of those cabinets because those cabinets
did not go all the way to the ceiling there was a
like a a ledge and I put those titans up
there just to give a little bit of backlight
and this is one of those scenes that Shaun likes
to talk about because there were so many people
and we had because of the covet regulations you
know anytime we change lights or move the camera
they all had to be cleared out so to to make that
simpler the camera is actually outside that house
there's a sliding glass door and a back patio
and the camera never got closer than to push
right into that door and it never got wider and it
never got wide enough to see the frame so there's
a little bit of push on some of these shots and
then the other thing is because the lights were
outside the window the guys could go and fiddle
with them and then those Astera Titan s were on
an app so in terms of turning them on and on off
and adjusting the level we did not have to go in
the room the only time we had to go in the room
is when we went in for coverage and we popped
the camera off the dana dolly and went inside and
then they would have to clear out and that's a lot
of people to clear out and bring back in and
then the front light you know just to just to
create that ambience behind us out of the sliding
glass windows was a great big 12 by ultra bounce
that was probably t-boned because it was it
was on a porch so you wouldn't have gotten the
12-foot height so they probably just t-boned
it and did like you know eight feet nine feet
whatever you could and and then popped a light
into it and I wanna say that light was probably
an airy sky panel I don't remember clearly
but I only had two m18s and if that's what's
playing outside the front then it had to be the
the airy sky panel creating that that soft light
and this is another one of those scenes
where I was a little bit nervous about that
that glare coming in that window you know I didn't
want it to obscure you know Joseph's mom's face
and and so we were just you know kind of careful
we would dial the level down because I still
wanted to be kind of blown out but I didn't want
it to be so bright that you know it was it was
like fogging up her face and again it was one of
the things that I worried about a little more than
Shaun did and John's like it's beautiful go
with it so but that was that was a fun scene
and we spent a lot of time we it feels like we
spent a half a day in that in that particular
location because we had several different day
scenes and we had a night scene and we had the
the masters and the close-ups I'm sure that's
not true I'm sure we didn't spend a half day but
you know probably at least a good three hours
you know just in that particular space and
beautifully lit thank you well this is a triumph
because you know this was another instance where
just like the bar my lights were going to be in
the shot and and you know I had to fight the urge
because you know starting out it's a cardinal sin
to have a light and a shot and it's funny I have
to tell you a story you know I won MTV VMA moon
man for the Moby we are all made of stars video
and there was one scene you know when we shot
that where he has got this kind of you know long
rock and roller hair and he's looking into a
mirror and and in the mirror I didn't notice
it when we shot it but later on I realized in the
mirror there's this little red fresnel lens I saw
a bloody light and I'm like how did I miss that
you know and it was red because it was gelled
and I was just like oh god you know and when they
announced on MTV that that that video had won for
best cinematography guess what clip they played
it was like just like rubbing salt into the wound
you know here's your award and here's your up
but anyway nobody else ever knew or cared and
if they did they're like he did it on purpose so
I did it on purpose everybody right maybe you're
mocking it so but anyway in the in the wide
tilt down in the scene you see both of them
what's just man Shaun had to reassure
me it looks like party lights I'm okay
and but what I did is when we shot them because
you're looking right at the light source even
though they're red to the naked eye they
clipped out and so the white rectangles
and I asked Keith Roush who did the
color grade I'm like would you please
create red rectangles and just track them so
that at least the front looks red which he did
so that's a fix that nobody would know but I just
thought they looked really crappy all blown out
they were really good at lighting the space but
and they were really bright these bloody things
but they were not so bright that they put the
rim lights on Kali and Joseph that is actually
Astera Titan s again on just on c-stands with the
red lights and because they're at the far end of
a barn so I'm bringing those those Astera Titan s
around to just get that sweet spot and and do that
red and and you know frankly that was that was
all my idea you know I was just like that's what I
want to do and then we start this scene in reverse
it's daytime and they come driving up on the golf
cart and then they walk just inside the doors
and this happens well after we flipped around
the sun went down so there was no front light and
I had to replicate this feeling of the glow coming
in the door and so the light on their face is not
daylight it's that same 12 by ultra bounce out the
door with a light popped into it and it certainly
was not the aries sky panels because both of them
are playing so it was it was an m18 that was
popped into that and and because it's so dim
you know it must have been scrimmed way down
and probably even closed the doors some you know
to waste some of the light just to create that
quality and so so that's that's what I did and I
liked it but the the highest compliment of all is
that is that one of Maria the still photographers
shots of this lighting setup is what Netflix used
for their their thumbnail and their advertising
and I'm like you know that's that's just you know
you can't have a better compliment than that and
you know you did a good job of picking some of
my favorite scenes there are some others that I
really like too but but these are all some of my
favorite lighting and you know like I was telling
you earlier about how I love that this movie let
me show off some different looks and different
styles I mean if we hadn't had you know the colors
and the barns if it was all in the house you know
we could get dramatic with it but it wouldn't you
know you wouldn't have the color you wouldn't have
you know that really dramatic range of different
flavors and so that's another thing that I really
appreciate this movie for is it really let me you
know have have fun with a lot of different looks.
What did you like about this video?